-Welcome, welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for being here.
Welcome. Welcome.
Did you read this today?
I thought this was
very interesting.
I saw that Costco is now
offering one-ounce gold bars
for $2,000.
And they're selling out.
Gold bars.
Yeah, even weirder,
at Kay Jewelers,
they're giving out
free cheese samples.
-Really?
-Yeah.
So if you're keeping track,
you can buy gold bars at Costco
no problem,
but CVS still keeps
their deodorant
locked behind bulletproof glass.
[ Laughter ]
"You want 24-hour protection?
I got to call my manager.
Hold on."
Some more business news --
Uber just announced
that you can now have drivers
deliver your return packages
to the post office,
FedEx, or UPS.
That makes sense.
At night,
they drive drunk people,
and in the morning,
they drive the stuff
that the drunk people order.
[ Laughter ]
Perfect.
-Circle of life.
-♪ The circle of life ♪
Well, big news from Washington.
Oh, my goodness.
Hey, quick show of hands.
Does anybody here want
to be Speaker of the House?
Okay.
Everybody is talking about this.
Kevin McCarthy
was ousted from his job,
and now there's no
Speaker of the House.
But next week, a vote
will be held to replace him.
And a lot of people
are calling it a thankless job
that's borderline impossible.
Yeah, it's not much fun.
And most Republicans say
that they're not interested.
They actually are using
special excuse generators
to get out of it.
I'll show you what I mean.
For instance,
when Congressman Mike Rodgers
was asked to run for speaker,
the generator told him to say...
-Oh.
-Do you see how it works?
They're just
giving them excuses.
-That was random?
-Let me show you. Random.
Next up, when Congressman
Jack Bergman was asked,
he said...
[ Laughter, applause ]
I mean, they're helping --
They want a way out of this.
So they use
the excuse generator.
Check this out.
When Congressman Michael Guest
was asked, he said...
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Wow.
-That's his job.
Here's another one.
When Congressman
Mark Amodei was asked,
he said...
[ Laughter ]
That's impossible.
-Wow.
-They don't make them.
-That's random.
-He's on the hunt.
-Yeah.
-You got to be safe.
-Got to be safe.
And next up, when Congressman
Austin Scott was asked,
he said...
[ Laughter ]
That's what he tells women
in bars.
-At bars.
-I don't know. Here's another.
When Congressman Chuck Edwards
was asked, he said...
[ Laughter ]
That's impossible.
That's hard to do.
And finally, when Congressman
John Carter was asked,
he said...
So these are just
some of the excuses.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile,
with Kevin McCarthy out,
North Carolina congressman
Patrick McHenry
will serve
as the interim speaker.
Yeah, Kevin McCarthy
and Patrick McHenry,
they have similar names,
so it's a little confusing.
Here, let me
break it down for you.
[ Rhythmic tapping ]
Kevin McCarthy.
Patrick McHenry.
McHenry. McCarthy.
Two men.
Same party.
McCarthy. McGarvey.
McCollum. McCaul.
McCarthy. McCarthy.
McCartney. McGraw.
McCarthy. McGovern.
McCormick. McBath.
McClellan. Mick Jagger.
McCheese. Back to Pat.
McCarthy. McGovern.
McLovin. McRib.
Matthew McConaughey.
Now back to Mick.
Kevin and Kevin
and Kevin and Matt.
Matt ousted Kevin,
and now we have Pat.
Patrick and Patty
and Patrick and Pat.
Kevin and Kevin James
meme format.
Pat McHenry after him.
Pat, Pat, Kev, Kev,
Matt, Matt, Jim.
I just hope that was --
I just hope that was helpful.
Are we okay?
Was that helpful?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I hope that was helpful, yeah.
That's right,
after McCarthy was voted out,
McHenry got to bang the gavel
for the first time as speaker.
Let's see how that went.
-The chair declares
the House in recess,
subject to the call
of the chair.
[ Sputters ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Trouble at home, Pat?
[ Laughter ]
Wow. That's pretty aggressive
with the gavel there.
Oh, I'm sorry. Hold on.
I'm getting word
that Patrick McHenry
is back in the House chamber
right now.
This is real. Can we go live
and see what he's up to?
The chair welcomes everyone
to today's session.
First order of business,
the chair recognizes
House Bill 3.817
to approve a short-term
spending bill.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next, the chair recognizes
Bill 413.5
to make guacamole free
at all Chipotles.
Ow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yow!
Next up, the chair declares
a new federal holiday --
Orville Redenbacher
Appreciation Day.
Don't at me.
[ Applause ]
Next, the chair
recognizes October 4th
as the official start
of pumpkin spice season.
August is too early.
November is too late.
It's settled.
Ow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next item on the agenda,
the chair declares
Travis Kelce and Taylor Swift
as the best couples Halloween
costume of the year.
No one slay, slay like Tay-Tay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pretty intense guy.
Pretty intense guy, like "Yow!"
Finally, officials in Australia
are warning people
to stay away from a swamp
that mysteriously
turned pink overnight.
Take a look at this thing.
-Ooh.
[ Audience groans ]
-Turns out it was the world's
worst crocodile gender reveal.